hey 42 here as of 2015 planet Earth is
home to seven billion people but the
population is estimated to reach up to
11 billion by 2050 that's an increase of
4 billion people in just 35 years well
researchers warned that planet Earth
cannot sustain 11 billion people is this
true is there a limit to how many people
can reasonably live on planet Earth and
if so what is that limit let's find out
in the past 50 years the human
population has increased exponentially
it took humans a hundred and fifty
thousand years for the population to
reach just 1 billion in 1850 then only a
hundred years later in 1950 the
population hit 2.5 billion and then took
just 60 more years to reach 7 billion
astonishingly at the current rate of
growth the planet's population increases
by 1 billion every 12 years this
phenomenal growth is mostly due to one
thing advances in medicine the invention
of penicillin for example but each and
every one of those 7 billion people
requires a minimum amount of food water
light shelter clothing education
medicine and other things to live an
adequate standard of life what food
doesn't come from nowhere it has to be
farmed and farming takes space lots and
lots of space a staggering 40% of the
earth's surface is now taken over by
farmland that's a lot when you consider
that in the 1700 s that figure was just
7% but how much of that arable land is
needed to farm enough food to sustain
just one human being that number is 2.1
hectares it takes 2.1 hectares of land
and water to provide for the average
human being but that's the average human
and the world is far from average the
average European uses 4.5 hectares but
America leads the world and food and
water consumption the average American
uses 10 hectares of land however the
world only has 4.1 billion hectares of
arable land and the vast majority of it
that can realistically be farmed is
already being farmed there is very
little left to go around
based on the worldwide average of 2.1
hectares for each person we currently
need 1.5 earths to sustain the current
population of seven billion and that's
based on the average level of
consumption if the whole world all 7
billion people lived at a European
standard we would need three point for
us to sustain everyone if however the
entire worlds population consume the
average American quantity of food and
water we would need five Earth's so it's
fair to say that were well beyond
capacity which partially explains why
over 1 billion people worldwide don't
have access to regular food or clean
water it's not the only reason but a
considerable factor so how many people
can the earth sustain well about
one-third less than it currently is the
unfortunate truth is that for developed
countries to live the way they currently
do the global consumption of food has to
be unbalanced sadly a vast portion of
the population has to starve for the
rest of the world to gorge themselves on
a daily basis
because they're quite simply isn't
enough food and water to go around if
you think that's bad it's nothing
compared to the problems we would face
if the population doubled from what it
is now currently one-third of all the
food produced in the world on a daily
basis is wasted it gets lost or thrown
away it is estimated that if we could be
totally efficient and don't waste any
food operating it maximum capacity the
earth could support up to 10 billion
people but there's a couch to feed 10
billion people not only what we have to
stop wasting food but the entire world
would need to go vegetarian farming
livestock is a horrendously inefficient
way to produce food you have to grow
crops to feed to the livestock a
significant portion of the crops
produced today aren't for feeding humans
they're for feeding animals that will
ultimately end up on our dinner plate
so to feed 10 billion people this
inefficient method of food production
would have to completely cease but
that's no fun
everyone loves chicken well not everyone
some people really really don't like
chicken but then of course there's the
health concerns an entirely vegetarian
diet doesn't provide enough protein and
humans are designed to eat protein it
serves innumerable essential functions
in our bodies such as repairing muscles
making em zines and hormones as well as
other things
generally speaking protein is a crucial
building block of bones muscle skin
cartilage and blood normally vegetarians
replace - like a protein in their diet
with food such as eggs and cheese but
all those require farmed animals to
produce on a large scale so in a world
of 10 billion people those foods are no
longer an option that these very few
sources of protein mainly tofu nuts and
seeds can you just imagine trying to
convince the whole world to eat only
tofu nuts seeds fruits vegetables grains
and potatoes nope I can't even it just
wouldn't work so what do we do what's
the ideal solution based on current
estimates the population in 2050 could
be as high as 11 billion way beyond what
the earth can reasonably support there
are three ways to solve this problem one
reduce the population to vastly reduce
our consumption of resources or three
improve our current technology to make
farming significantly more productive so
that each plot of farmland produces
double the amount of food it currently
does doubling the productivity sounds
like a lot but research has shown that
that is what will be required to feed 10
billion people so believe it or not
there is hope doubling our productivity
sounds unachievable but based on history
it can be achieved in the 17th century
industrialized nations managed to triple
their farming productivity by inventing
new types of grain and mechanizing
farming techniques so who knows what the
future of farming technology holds it
may not sound appetizing but in an
overpopulated world we may even have to
resort to eating sin
besides food grown in a lab but don't
start stocking up on tins of beans just
yet sit down and chill the hell out
because there's new research that
suggests we may never get to 10 billion
people statistics show that in the
developed world the average number of
children families are having is
declining but in Africa it's increasing
this map shows the average number of
children families in every country has
the average for most of Europe is one to
two children America to two free
children and thanks to their
controversial one child per family
policy China also has an average of one
to two per family some countries in
Africa on the other hand have an average
of six to seven children per family why
is that it has very little to do with a
desire for more children the main
problem is a lack of contraception over
half of all Africans would like to use
birth control but only 30 percent of the
country has access to it as you can see
on this map of worldwide contraception
usage in many African countries only 6%
of the population has access to or uses
birth control and by no means blaming
Africans themselves for this the problem
lies of politics economics and to a
smaller extent education and commonly
held religious beliefs surrounding
contraception so what's the ideal number
of children to stop the worldwide
population spiraling out of control in
30 years time 2.1 children per family
that is what is known as the fertility
replacement level if the average number
of children every family had in the
world dropped to 2.1 then the population
would never increase because to children
is just enough to replace their parents
when they pass on if the whole world
averaged 2.1 children per family then
the global population would stabilize at
its current level there is some proof
that this is actually happening right
now the average number of children per
family globally is decreasing studies by
the United Nations shows that the
fertility rates in the majority of
countries is slowly decreasing so we may
never reach 10 billion some optimistic
Esther
predict the population will stabilize at
around nine billion if we were to be
sensible about our consumption of
resources and prevent waste wherever
possible then the earth can absolutely
support nine billion people just who
knows what will happen in 30 years time
but there are things we can do now to
prevent a global famine in the future we
can help and educate less developed
nations and provide better health care
and access to birth control developed
countries can vastly reduce their
resource consumption and prevent waste
and most importantly we can care for and
preserve the Earth's natural resources
instead of carelessly destroying them
for profits because Nature more than
anything else is supporting human life
as we know it thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42
you